NEGATIVE REACTION.
TARIFFS IN JULY.
>> Bret: KEVIN CORKE OF THE
POLITICS AND THE OTHER STORIES
OF THE DAY.
BRIT HUME IS HERE TONIGHT.
JUST BEFORE WE CAME OUT HERE,
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED ABOUT THE
STORY.
SURPRISED THAT HARLEY-DAVIDSON
I FOUGHT HARD FOR THEM AND
ULTIMATELY THEY WILL NOT PAY
TARIFFS SELLING INTO THE E.U.,
WHICH HAS FOR US BADLY ON TRADE.
THOUGHTS ON THAT?
>> I WOULD INTERPRET "BE
PATIENT," JUST LET THIS GO FOR A
WHILE HARLEY-DAVIDSON, DON'T DO
ANYTHING.
I THINK WE WILL GET A DEAL OUT
OF THAT AND EVERYONE WILL BE
AND IT'S NOT EVEN REALLY CLEAR
WHAT NEGOTIATIONS ARE UNDERWAY.
SO I CAN UNDERSTAND THE
PRESIDENT'S DESIRE TO TAMP THIS
DOWN BECAUSE IT IS AN
EMBARRASSING RESULT.
>> Bret: BUT ON THE BIG
PICTURE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS
DOES IT PAY OFF DOWN THE ROAD?
>> THIS IS THE ISSUE THAT HAS
BEDEVILED TRADING NATIONS FOR AS
LONG AS THERE HAS BEEN SUCH
THINGS.
NATIONS ENGAGED IN AN UNFAIR
TRADE PRACTICE.
TARIFFS THEMSELVES COULD BE
UNFAIR TRADE PRACTICE.
THEY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THEIR
ECONOMIES AND THEIR
DISADVANTAGES OF OTHERS, AND
IT'S NOT FAIR.
WE HAVE A SET OF RULES TO BE
IT TAKES TOO LONG AND IT'S TOO
BUREAUCRATIC.
THAT LEAVES YOU WITH WHAT OTHER
WEAPON IN HAND?
TARIFFS.
SO IN A SENSE, YOU END UP
FIGHTING TRADE PRACTICES WITH
TARIFFS.
NOW TARIFFS CAN BE EFFECTIVE AND
AND IF YOU TRIGGER A TRADE WAR
IN WHICH YOU GO TIT FOR TAT,
TIT FOR TAT, PRETTY SOON YOU
HAVE A BIGGER THAN THE NATION
SITUATION GOING ON LIKE WE HAD
DURING THE DEPRESSION AND
EVERYBODY LOSES.
THAT'S THE DANGER, THE PRESIDENT
MAKE IT DEALS OUT OF THIS AND IT
MAY WORK BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT, IS PLAYING WITH FIRE.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
STABILITY STORY.
YOU HEARD CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE
WATERS WALKING BACK YOUR
AND GET IN THEIR FACE AFTER THE
SARAH SANDERS INCIDENT OVER THE
PLAY WELL WITH THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE NO MATTER YOUR POLITICAL
AFFILIATION.
BUT IT DOES EXEMPLIFY THE
EXTREMES TO WHICH PEOPLE ARE
GOING AND THE EXTREMES TO WHICH
PEOPLE ARE FEELING IN REACTION
TO THIS PRESIDENT.
I'M NOT SAYING IT IS HIS FAULT
BUT PEOPLE RESPONDING TO THEM IN
THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY WAY.
EVERY TIME HE DOES OR SAYS
SOMETHING, WHAT HAPPENS IS,
EXTRAPOLATING FROM HIS SOMETIMES
NOT VERY CLEAR LANGUAGE, PEOPLE
DOING OR TRYING TO DO AND REACTS
TO THEM ACCORDINGLY.
THE NEXT THING YOU KNOW YOU ARE
I DON'T THINK IT WILL PLAY VERY
WELL AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
MAXINE WATERS WAS TALKING ABOUT
IS HARMFUL.
IT'S NOT PHYSICAL HARM BUT IT'S
HARM NONETHELESS.
I THINK SHE WILL BE QUIETED BY
HER COLLEAGUES.
>> Bret: AND OBVIOUSLY THE
PRESIDENT HAS A HISTORY OF BEING
A COUNTER PUNCH HER, HE TWEETED
OUT, YOU MAY NOT BE HAPPY WITH
WHAT YOU ARE ASKING FOR.
>> RIGHT WHICH IS IMMEDIATELY
TAKEN AS A VEILED THREAT.
A THREAT TO DO WHAT?
OVER AGAIN.
WE NEED TO STOP ALL THIS AND
BEGIN TO BEHAVE IN A CIVILIZED